[музика]
[оплески]
А цей Фартовий у
нас вставляємо і гладеньким молоточком
просто
[музика]
її
Ну то вже буде свято якраз Ялинка буде
добре в нас Минулого року була проблема
з ялинкою бо тут ялинок рипких немає
сосон насправді в цій от
місцевості атмосфера
Різдва приємно пахне як засніжені степи
Донеччини як мелена кава у прифронтовій
[музика]
хатині і звучить я як сміх воїна
що вижив після бою зляхався я
якраз Я тоже як раптова тиша після
безсонної
ночі радує як Усмішка дитини в екрані
мобільного
телефону і муркоче як кіт якого забрали
зі згарища А як її звуть кітка
ка
свято - це гріє як окопна
свічка як грілка в тактичних
рукавицях воно смакує як польовий
борщ як волонтерське куття і вселяє Віру
як вцілілий хрест у розбомбленої
церкви як Тиха молитва Під час евакуації
пораненого Дай мні достатьйого боже Дай
мні достатьйого
я пої не говор
тут Різдво таке ж неосяжне як любов і
віра рідних що чекають вдома міцне як
залізний купол протиповітряної оборони
над мирними містами і гостре як ока
захисника що збиває
балістику Дух Різдва Це відчуття родини
це здатність дарувати турботу і приймати
її не зламна впевненість у перемозі яким
би важким і довгим не був до неї шлях і
нехай Господь у Святий вечір подарує
Віру тим кого похитнули важкі
випробування І нехай родини зберуться за
одним
столом хоч дехто і на відстані в тисячі
кілометрів і нехай Господь подарує
Україні мир а загарбникам справедливий
суд
Я майже кожен рік проводжу в зоні
бойових дій і кожен раз я намагаюсь
зробити якесь свято Ну от мені поприколу
типу воно якось так атмосферненько
виходить на війні просто все помножено
там умовно кажучи їх 100 кожна емоція
яка на гражданському житті тут вона
відчувається там радість за побратимо в
когось там народилась дитина хтось там
одружився Хтось ще щось ну тобто це от
така велика сім'я яка радується за
кожного росіяни гатили з усього що могли
там більше години градами на ураганами
ствольною артилерією і командир групи
десь наш приволік ми жили в маленькому
підвалі там людей на п'ять приволік
маленьку ялиночку таку там десь знайшов
маленькі іграшки ми її на нарядили десь
знайшли якісь дитяче шампанські якісь
місцеві принесли олів'є ще якісь були
страви Я пам'ятаю і ми в такому е колі
можна сказати сімейному відсвяткували Це
було дуже атмосферно насправді коли
навколо я ж кажу все розривається коли
ситуація така напружена і навіть в цьому
пекліді В тебе є таке маленьке свято це
класно є така японська мудрість яка каже
що не треба вчитись ховатись від грози
треба навчитись танцювати під дощем
тобто Ми давно звикли жити в умовах
війни і навчили радуватись і там якісь
моменти мати позитивні тому Життя
продовжується нам роки життя ніхто не
поверне І що ми провели на війні Тому
треба навчатись жити під час війни і
Життя
продовжується ну зараз трохи складіша
ситуація ворог здійснює певні штурмові
дії намагається захопити наші позиції
покращити своє положення
застосовує всі види тактичного озброєнь
починаючи від авіації реактивної
артилерії ствольної артилерії але
дякувати Богу
тримаємося просто Головне що хлопців
шкода багато поранених оце
погано а як будете святкувати Різдво
напередку бо їду міняти
хлопці їду міняти хлопців будемо на
цьому їдемо там напередку на евакуації
ми тут не буде сткую Різдво і нічого не
чекає але чекаю Що до нього усі люди які
тут доживуть і зможуть оскувати його як
вони б цього
хотіли
змігранич в дроні Да да да
подарунок якусь там маленьку ялиночку
всі нарядять але в основному стараємся
на такі свята не щось тут організувать а
щось організувать там для наших сусідів
вони дати люблять вони ви їм подарунки
носите конечно ми вискочили Я кажу ми
фартові капелан каже пита то фартові
чи чи Бог поміг Я кажу фарт подарував
Бог бажаю щоб країні подарував Бог фарт
а найбільший фарт це буде коли Путін
здохне і побажав би як в золотої рибки в
анекдоті знаєш каже огородити
Раш
бетоном ні високим плотом і залити
бетоном Ну і щоб був спокій на нашій
українській землі Звичайно що хочеться
щоб всі вдома святкували Різдво новий
рік з родинами з
дітьми будували своє майбутнє вірили в
цю країну здоров'я щастя і миру в
Україні щоб вигнати
тих не буду я виражатися грубо будемо
всі разом відмічати свята і Різдво і
Новий рік ну Саме основне триматись
єднатись
і все буде добре все буде Україно Та ну
щоб війна закінчилась нашою перемогою
звісно а там уже як далі буде то ми самі
розберемося гоглавне перемога то що ми
не втомимось український народ буде
боронити свою землю і відстоювати це
факт
бажаю щоб був святковий настрій щоб люди
відчували перспективу це дуже важливо
перспективу для себе і перспективу для
України вірю що Україна буде в
Європейському Союзі і в НАТО вдома щоб
були всі здорові для моєї родини Це був
тяжкий рік через втрату брата
Олега який героїчно загинув на війні Але
тим не менше Я маю надію що його смерть
і смерть багатьох хлопців
і здоров'я котре втрачене на цій війні
Що це недаремно а для майбутнього його
дітей дітей всієї України що ми не
будемо повертатися
до сходу і усвідомлювати то що наше
майбутнє тільки там на
заході
все можливе щоб наблизити
перемогу Христос с рождає славімо
його даруй
літа щасливії
му дому
господарю бу
радість
стала яка
небувала на
твертебом зліда ясна
би світ
[музика]
засіяла